i know you guys have had multiple offers
to
sell the company and i'm sure spack how
do you how do you think about that
is it is a spac interesting for a
company at your scale now
yeah i mean you know we we definitely
get inbounds on it i think for us it's
how do we figure out the right capital
structure to deliver the most value for
customers
and i think you know we spax can add a
lot of pressure being public
i so after a year banking i spent nine
years at a hedge fund by the way before
coming to aura
and so like you know seeing that world i
think there's a time that's appropriate
for i do like the rigor
the financial markets give you and you
know i think um you know there's
something about a company that operates
wells
you know when all lies are on it but i
think you know we're still pretty early
in our story so i think you know we
we've got a
we've got a lot to iterate on a lot more
to prove and deliver more value to
customers and i think if we do that then
the appropriate
you know stay private next round go
public you know
you know people want to buy you i think
you know all that's open
i will say the m a side if you look at
it just in the last
year you saw google close on fitbit
amazon launch a wearable and pretty
significant rumors have fair we know
facebook's trying to launch one too
yeah so if you look at the space i think
you sort of have apple at like 50
million apple watches in 2020
and then fitbit you know at like 10 to
12 million units behind is the number
two ish right
and so like i think if you're everyone
else in the space you're like google
amazon you're like holy cow this apple
watch trend has continued
this is important you know health is a
you know 10 trillion 20 trillion dollar
problem globally
like we're losing this battle and we
need to catch up so i definitely think
you're seeing you know people realize
like consumers want more of this
especially after pandemic you know
wearables numbers globally you know
accelerated and consumer demands
accelerating and the use cases are
expanding so as you go from
call it step tracking wearables 1.02 i
think really understanding health
wearables 2.0
you know i think i think we're in a
really good spot and i think that's what
consumers want and that's what
you know we're trying to focus on as a
company